إذا كانت فرحتك في عطلة الشتاء تتلاشى ،
فأنت لست وحيدًا ، كما أن إبقاء الأطفال
مستمتعين ليس بالأمر السهل في الآونة الأخيرة ،
لقد سمعت الكثير من الأطفال يقولون إن
لعب ألعاب الفيديو هو
نشاطهم المفضل ، لذا أود أن
أحاول رؤيته  تقول
الدكتورة جينا روبنسون من
مستشفى الأطفال في كليفلاند كلينك
إن هناك طرقًا صحية
للحفاظ على حركة الأطفال إذا كنت تعيش في مناخ أكثر برودة
حيث يوجد
خوض معركة بالثلج أو قم ببناء زلاجة ثلجية
، كما أن التزلج يمكن أن يحافظ على
نشاطهم إذا لم يكن الشتاء أبيضًا ، اذهب
إلى المكتبة
لالتقاط بعض الكتب ، وقم بالسير في الحديقة للحصول على بعض الهواء النقي
، وقم ببعض الفنون والحرف الداخلية  أو حتى
خبز بعض ملفات تعريف الارتباط إذا كان طفلك قد حصل على
لعبة فيديو خلال العطلة ،
يقول روبنسون إنه من المهم مشاهدة
وقت الشاشة ، سأحاول وضع حدود
وحدود قبل أن
تخرج الألعاب وأقول ذلك  s هو مقدار الوقت المتاح
لنا للألعاب إذا كنت ترغب في السماح
لهم بكسب بضع دقائق إضافية عن طريق القيام
بالأعمال المنزلية أو المهام في جميع أنحاء المنزل ، وهذه
طريقة أخرى لجعلهم يشعرون
أنهم قادرون على الحصول على مزيد من الوقت ولكننا لا نفعل ذلك
حقًا  لا أرغب في قضاء وقت غير محدود في
اللعب طوال اليوم ،
مما يجعل الأطفال نشيطين يساعدون في الحصول على
بعض الطاقة والتغلب على الملل حتى
لا تتركك العطلة الشتوية في
البرد لدقيقة صحية ، فأنا ماندي أحتاج